hey man it's me kevin smith uh welcome
to a scene study
of mall rats ladies and gentlemen uh
we're going to take a look
at the stan lee scene from mall rats let
me tell you something i put this in the
movie because i was a big fan of stan
lee and brody had to talk to
somebody in the world of comics and why
not of course stan lee
um putting this scene in the movie was
the about the most brilliant thing i
ever did for my
entire [ __ ] career a career that's
gone up it's gone down it's done some
[ __ ] sometimes people like me sometimes
people like you [ __ ] suck
um stan lee being in mall rats
is something that gave my career a lift
even to this [ __ ] day like
it was nuts like when we put him in mall
rats it was almost
like we created a world where everybody
knew who stan lee was
that didn't exist in 1995 comic book
people knew who he was but that was
about
it we wound up being in a world where
everyone did know
who stan lee was before he [ __ ] died
with all those cameos and the marvel
movies and stuff
so his first cameo as himself
uh is in this movie now some would argue
and say his first cameos himself is in a
movie called
the ambulance i think it is with eric
roberts eric roberts works at a comic
book company that could be marvel and
stan is in it
um but the most memorable first
appearance of stan lee as stanley
i would like to think is uh in mall rats
and uh that was borne out
in years later like 24 or 23 years later
in captain marvel when we find stan's
cameo in that movie uh him playing
himself
on a train reading the mall rat script
by kevin smith oh this marvel fan
[ __ ] wet himself got hard and came
all at the same [ __ ] time it was nuts
so the origins of that moment in captain
marvel
are this scene is right here in mall
rats and stan couldn't have been
lovelier um he arrived on set that day
we had cue cards for him because at that
point like he was like 73 or something
like that
i'll never forget one of our producers
jim jacks being like
he's a 73 year old old man be careful
with him because he could [ __ ] die at
any minute
p.s stan lee lived to be 96 so like you
know and
and psp pps he outlived jim jacks the
guy that was looking out for him
we have stan lee in the movie because of
jim jacks i had written the first draft
of mall riots or the first not even the
first draft the first scenes i'd write
and then i'd fax those pages to jim
jackson los angeles
so jim said this scene where brody's
talking to a combo guru
who's that meant to be i was like well i
guess it'd be kind of like a stan lee or
something like that
and he goes why don't you just make it
for stan lee and i was like i don't know
stan lee and he goes well i do
and i was like hollywood is good these
[ __ ] know each other and [ __ ]
so jim reached out to stan and was just
like hey man
this kid wants you to be in mall rats he
had uh lunch with him once a month jim
and stan would go to dantana's
because jim was a big comic book fan and
he would just take stan
out pick his brain and [ __ ] like
always trying to figure out a movie to
do with them and stuff
so this is years ago 1995. so he goes
out to dinner with him and i give him
the pages for the stan lee scene
and uh jim calls me as like new midnight
my time and nine o'clock his time and
[ __ ] at west coast
that's how to go and he goes well i
think it went okay stan wants to talk to
you i said sam wants to talk to me
he said yeah before he commits or says
anything he needs to talk to you he says
so are you going to call him tomorrow oh
my god absolutely what do you say about
the pages
he goes you call him you talk to him i
was like come on jim and he goes well
you want to know exactly what he said i
said yeah
and he goes he read the pages and he
said jim i would never say this [ __ ]
and so i had to explain to him that he's
a fictional version of himself but he
has a very important question he asks
wants to ask you before he can say yes
to doing this and so
never forget that first phone call
hearing that voice i heard it on
spider-man and his amazing friends and
all the interviews i've ever seen stan
do and [ __ ] like that
but here i was hearing on the other end
of the phone and uh i s
phone gets answered i said uh hello he
said hi this is stan lee i said oh my
god i know who you are
i said how are you man and he goes
wonderful
excellent to meet you thank you for
thinking of putting me in your movie
and i was like that you know thank god
you know jim i was like you're a legend
sir and i bloom for a while
and he goes thank you he's like but i
just want to talk to you about this
movie i would love to be in it
i would love to play myself i'm a big
ham that's oh fantastic he's going but
we got a problem so what's the problem
he goes you have me saying to the brody
character at one point uh reminiscing
about the girl that got away
he goes and that's great it's a
beautiful scene but if i go in some
movie playing myself talking about the
girl that got away
the girl i got at home will lock me out
of the house he's like i can't do that
to joni he loved his wife joan
so he's like i can't have people
thinking that there was someone other
than joan it's always been jones so
can i have another moment after this
scene
where i tell his friend you know that
like
this was all a setup that it wasn't real
that i was just kidding to make his
friend feel good
and i was like oh my god how sweet are
you absolutely for love
yes we'll absolutely do that i always
thought it was so incredibly
[ __ ] endearing you didn't want to
hurt joni's feelings years later
after knowing stan for a while like also
figured out what it was it was strategic
as [ __ ]
because what stan did was get himself
another scene in the movie
just like that he was like can i have
another scene where i tell the guy it's
fake i'm like yeah i guess that makes
sense we should do that
so he was he was uh he was cunning man
um i love him to death i miss him to
this very day
and if you miss him too you'll enjoy
this scene the stan lee
scene from all rats starring stan lee as
himself
and jason lee as brody
you looking at that couple inside
actually i was just looking at this uh
little pink number over here
oh yeah that's kind of nice they look
happy don't they
what the bras no the couple they look
happy
i guess as far as couples go you know
it reminds me of an issue of spider-man
i did
when peter parker and gwen stacy went
lingerie shopping
of course the green goblin showed up and
he pumpkin bombed the hell out of the
place
but aside from that it it's pretty much
the same thing
oh my god holy [ __ ]
aren't you oh stanley hi
they're fantastic for reed richards can
his whole body stretch
i mean every part you know like is hey i
know what you mean
we never really tackled stuff like that
in the old days i mean
what with the comic book code and all i
can't believe i'm standing here
talking to you you're responsible for
the greats let's do the list spider-man
guilty the incredible hulk afraid so oh
man this is so cool the x-men
now that you mention it [ __ ] man you are
a god
hey look at that couple boy they sure
seem to be in love huh
you know what's with that that's the
second time you've commented on couples
in love
well i i like that sort of thing tell me
do you have a girlfriend brody
had one we just broke up the thing
is this dork made of orange rock like
the rest of his body it's a superhero
secret
tell me brody why did you and your
girlfriend break up
she was a pain in the ass she wanted me
to be this typical boyfriend guy said i
was too into my own world
comics and all yeah i can relate
there was a time when it was all about
comics for me you know i
i had a girl probably the same as yours
she always complained that i spent too
much time with my own comics
and uh eventually we broke up see what
did she know here you are now a legend
in the field probably had a slew of
women's censor am i right
oh lots of women jagger and me we had a
running contest to see who had the most
matter of fact last time i looked i was
way ahead damn that's hot
but i never forgot that girl well did
you ever get back together with her
one day i found out she got married i
had blown it i had
uh missed my window no way
what'd you do i went on with my life
i created some special new superheroes
uh they were characters that reflected
my own
heartbreak and my own regrets how so dr
doom
where's body armor to conceal his own
mangled form
right yeah okay that was me
beneath the armor the hulk a normal guy
one minute
a rage of emotions the next just like me
when i thought about what i'd given up
so you created each character as a way
to do with your one big regret
yeah the girl that got away look
do yourself a favor brody don't wait
because all the money
all the women even all the comic books
in the world
they can't substitute for that one
person
i don't know all the comics in the world
trust me true believer
well good talking to you keep up all the
good work
you keep reading them i'll keep writing
them
hey stan yeah
she really meant that much to you brody
i'd give it all up
all of it for just one more day with her
take care
stan hi hey hey you know i think he
bought it yeah yeah what kind of story
did you give him
oh it was the vulture soliloquy you know
from the spider-man anniversary issue
love be a vulture tonight yeah well i
can't thank you enough
oh forget it but you know i think you
ought to get him some help
he seems to be really hung up on
superhero sex organs
but he'll outgrow it okay hey kids did
you like that
all these movies are available on itunes
or netflix in some places
amazon and other places you can find
them they're available patronize them if
you will uh
also if you like this kind of stuff come
on over to that kevin smith club
go to thatkevinsmithclub.com join up man
i do wake and bake three times a week
where i wake up just smoke weed with
y'all and stuff
come to that kevin smith club for more
video antics with kevin smith